ينضم الينا من الدوحه في الثقيل مراسل
صباح العربيه انا في صباحك اهلا بك بدنا
نسمع هالمره اجواء مباراه الارجنتين
كرواتيا في الدوحه كيف كانت
اييه اهلا صيام واهلا نادين طبعا بالامس
انا حضرت المباراه
كمشجع وخط التجربه كامله قبل الاتزان
الملعب وفي الملعب وبعد
ههه
طبعا انا بكون في المقابله هذه كلها مبتسم
طبعا نادين تعرف السبب همم
ههه
امس كانت الاجواء جدا همم جميله في الملعب
لاول مره استاد الوسيله وهو اكثر اكثر
ملعب في همم كاس العالم يمتلئ بالطاقه
الاستيعابيه الكامله كانت جماهير
الارجنتيني هي همم
الاغلبيه كان هناك هناك لبعض المشاهد اللي
لفتت نظري انه همم كان في مناوشات ما بين
الجماهير البرازيليه وايضا الجماهير
الارجنتينيه يعني هناك يعني بعض الجمايل
البرازيليه ما زالت متواجده وحضرت امس في
همم في محيط الملعب وقد تكون شرط حتى
التذاكر اعتبارا انه البرازيل ستكون في
نصف النهائي وكانت تدعم كرواتيا رغم ان
كرواتيا اخرجت البرازيل في المقابل همم
الجماهير الارجنتينيه يعني حتى رغمتها الى
النهائي لم تنسى البرازيل وكاله اغلب في
تفاتها كنت متواجد معهم طبعا اغلب وتفاكهه
كانت موجهه ضد همم البرازيل
اليوم يناير هل لاحظتوا انه الاستعدادات
بدات على قدم وساق منذ ليله امس استعدادا
لمباراه اليوم الحاسمه ايضا
بخصوص المنتخب المغربي توافد عدد كبير جدا
من الجماهير العربيه لدعم المنتخب المغربي
بشكل ملفد ودعيني احكي لك يعني قصه قبل
امس مساءا ثوره شائعه في اوساط الجماعي
بالعربيه والجماهير المغربيه انه سيتم
توزيع تذاكر مجانيه في محيط الملعب همم
استاذ همم البيت الساعه 10:00 صباحا
بالامس تخيل ان الجماهير المغربيه
والجماهير العربيه ذهبت همم اغطيتها ونامت
بالقرب من الملعب تاهبا اللي استلام
التذاكر في العاشر الصباح صباحا وكانت هي
مجرد شائعه ولم يتسلم احد او لم يتم
توزيعه اي تذكره في محيط الملعب فهذا يعني
يعكس لك جانب كبير من التوقف والحماس وهمم
الدعم الكبير الذي يحضر فيه المنتخب همم
وان شاء الله انه نحتفل همم تاهل المغرب
الى نهائي كاس العالم
شكرا جزيلا لك من الدوحه الجميله المراسل
صباح العربيه شكرا يا نايف